it is June 16 2023 and you are watching
the code report as we Edge closer and
closer to the singularity more and more
crazy stuff is going to happen in Tech
in today's video I have five crazy
stories to share with you about things
you should know about as a developer
this week let's get started with some
bad news Google domains is shutting down
or more accurately being sold to
Squarespace this announcement came out
of nowhere and was pretty shocking to me
as a Google domains Customer because
Google rarely kills its own products
except for stadia Hangouts Duo Google
Plus android things loon angularjs and a
few hundred others in addition just a
few weeks ago they announced a bunch of
new top level domains like dot dad and
dot zip and I'm the proud owner of kung
da Foo but apparently you guys didn't do
your part and buy enough of these
domains to make the platform viable for
Google and that means I now have to call
myself a Squarespace developer that's
pretty bad but it's nothing compared to
what Russia's killnet is about to do to
the global banking system they teamed up
with Anonymous Sudan and a few other
friends to make these extremely cheesy
videos letting the world know about
their upcoming attack while in advance
within 48 hours we are launching This
Global company nothing will save you and
this is not a warning I am just
informing you have never seen such
problems before we are killing it now
there were some actual cyber attacks on
U.S government infrastructure yesterday
but as of right now the banking system
is still intact we knew stuff like this
was going to happen because our friends
at the world economic Forum have been
worrying about it for the last few years
the frightening scenario of a
comprehensive Cyber attack the covid-19
crisis would be seen in this respect as
a small disturbance in comparison and as
expected it's playing out like a
Hollywood movie while simultaneously we
have aliens landing in people's
backyards I told you 2023 was gonna get
weird now lately I managed to restrain
myself from talking about artificial
intelligence but open AI just released a
really cool new feature called functions
which allows gpt4 to format responses
that could execute your own back-end
code basically it allows gpt4 to Output
Json in a more deterministic way as a
developer you provide an array of
functions that it can call which allows
it to format the responses in Json with
the correct arguments and data types and
that makes it far easier to build chat
Bots that execute your own code speaking
of AI versel just released a brand new
npm package called AI I tried it out
myself and it's by far the quickest and
easiest way to build an AI chatbot I'll
have a full tutorial on my second
Channel soon so make sure you're
subscribed over there but what makes it
so cool is that that it provides helpers
for streaming text responses that allow
you to recreate that typing effect that
you get in apps like chat GPT in
addition it integrates with all the
major llms on platforms like anthropic
cohere hugging face and of course open
AI next we have an update on Reddit
which is still currently on fire there's
still close to 5 000 subreddits in
private mode which has been extended
from 48 hours to indefinitely until
Reddit provides Fair API pricing Reddit
CEO Steve Huffman is prepared to die on
this hill and a leaked internal email
showed him downplaying the impact of the
protest which made people even more
angry and that means we may never get
our beloved programmer humor subreddit
back at least until they kick out the
mods and reopen it manually this has
been the code report thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one